so I had to do this thing called so
people know how to give a [ __ ] but
people I'm on a show coming out and
anyway spit it out and be proud of it
I'm on a show so check it out I'm on a
sitcom yeah called splitting up together
Jenna Fischer on Oliver Hudson anywho
big names pretty good but um we got the
best possible spot so we got does that
mean
Tuesday night check it out March 27th it
goes Rosanna right no check it out the
middle Oh a new episode of blackish
oh and then our show so Tuesday's comedy
now not only that we cope they're gonna
put it on again the next night after
Modern Family a brand new modern family
has that been announced officially oh
yeah they did today said I could say it
yeah okay
and that's two nights they're gonna show
our show that's a huge those are huge
lead us you cannot get better than that
if they said you're gonna be at Friday
at 11:00 after so yeah yeah yeah yeah
it'd be like oh they don't like it hate
it yeah but then we so I go to this
thing this TCA think we're all the
critics are and get the [ __ ] go on a
red carpet do all that [ __ ] right
I do the red card we do a casting and
then the president of ABC goes I want to
be in it so she got in it riot which is
a great sign but then here's what
happened before that
this is where the god gift happened the
law god law but God law it is so I show
up and I first of all you know you show
up and everyone shows up at the same
time and so when people are getting out
of their cars
you have assistants and people coming
from ABC going oh mister
you know mr. Lee not mr. Lee but like
they'll go to like mr. breath cuz Zach
Braff was there mr. breath you know come
to the table isn't that the first five
people that walked up to me goes are you
press well it straight up straight up
like you're in the wrong area you're in
Pratt you press is on the other side of
the building and he go no I'm honest
then you're on a show yeah
what show splitting up together and then
they have to look at look at paperwork
oh yeah I guess yeah but like every five
people I have to go in right nightmare
it's here's another thing that happened
did you notice I wasn't wearing a tie in
that photo yeah what happened here they
yanked it off my body publicist - vamos
- oh that's awful tie they yanked it off
I bought it and then they set me up to a
room to cover my [ __ ] lesions on my
face you mean your livers my liver spots
really yes I'm in a private room they're
putting like make this special liver
spot make up for like diseased Asian
faces okay like what says Alfie
Sullivan's and peaky blinders you know
how his face is all crusty why that's
what I have you have what do you call it
curvy so that's not so then they go you
know your your you know your little -
earlier I go okay do you pick me up
right they go go to the bar so I go to
the bar and I see Oliver Hudson who's on
the show hang out with somebody he's
sitting with all the executives at ABC
because Bob come on over this is good
it's not because I don't know what to do
he doesn't she asked her I'm gonna I'm
gonna fart I'm gonna do something say
something racist you know man you build
the fun cakes in those situations no
ma'am yeah not in a super high pressure
it's almost like he morphs into a minor
and also the inner voice says just don't
say anything if you don't say anything
then it's even right it's zero zero yeah
the game right you're not gonna win but
you're not gonna lose either so don't
say anything you could potentially lose
by being a dud why sometimes when I'm in
a place and I'm like god that person was
a dud you know it's like people were
just out there it's like they're saying
nothing not
to anything yeah they are you spy yeah
you know but so but my thing is okay so
you come you go over there I could have
said a lot of things that I would
normally do you're like oh yeah that fat
[ __ ] you know me I could just say things
but I don't know who they I don't know
right you don't know your audience
so I shut the [ __ ] up I'm just sitting
there and now people think that I'm
being eccentric that's that's a term the
people use to describe me and I'm no
more I don't know what it means you know
who Howard Hughes was [ __ ] eccentric
is that you say eccentric eccentric
alright I'm not that's I'm not a crazy
person people know it's a good thing
you're weird you're off in beat no I
want to be normal or I want people to go
oh he could babysit my kids not oh you
can like you know paint a mural in the
backyard
that's what I look like like a [ __ ]
Basquiat goose khyati yeah yeah young
Bob and so I I don't say nothing and now
it's kind of like people are asking the
question so you just stand up right oh
my god small talk they [ __ ] know you
do stand-up no but you know yeah they do
it like just weird and they're just
people just eating talking you know
so you're bombing right now but like big
time your your phone or no so then this
is what I hear you have to gather the
porn okay so that just listen to what I
have to say okay what I hear is this you
have to yeah the corn as loud as one
could say that now if you don't know my
act back 15 years ago I used to have a
joke where my dad said you have to sell
the car right quiet riot so I go okay
that's a joke from 15 years ago but it
was dead-on
she was perfect did the accent very good
very good shadows I look up and it's
Roseanne Barr
whoa poor you know everyone points at
the table goes there now the focus is on
me and I and then my face I mean that's
and I got up you know I shook her hand I
think she goes I'm a big fan of this guy
forever forever everybody right thank
you so much you know I'm Eli I'm like
I'm blushing
jean-bob yeah john bobbitt guys know
each other
no no better was a guy live it's a god
like god laughs well you guys knew each
other
no she knows her stand-up she but that
was a joke I haven't told him 15 years
to write and she remembered it and then
she leaves right and now the attentions
on me and and then everyone just starts
to laughing at me
but which is a good thing yeah they go
look you should have seen your face they
said right and they're like one of their
executives like I'm so scared like I'm
so nervous I'm such a big fan that
that's my first interaction with her
that was amazing you know and then you
know it became looser and you know I
mean I don't and then I'm going through
the line with Lindsay Price and because
all these people see the show they saw
three episodes and all that I'm not
kidding you it's not in my head it's on
[ __ ] camera people would go oh yeah
you guys are on the show because I mean
they had paired me lead you're amazing
Lindsay on it she is amazing though but
nothing for me nothing gone
okay nothing so I think this season I
just slid by you know the performances
were a little iffy maybe they cut the
scenes down a bit no I think but you
know what could I say something sell
yourself short you were great
but I think that Lindsay is a seasoned
actor and she she is a very you know to
her credit she's a very I love her there
yeah god bless her I take care ok let's
take a ticket
Bob bless you'll take care good bye
Lindsay goodbye Lindsay your job
but yeah goose kiyow kiyow kiyow gooks
kyun kid that's the shirt with me and
Lily with like little he had what do you
call it dread dread yeah happy cool
[Music]